Abracadabra youtubers, it's Charlie
BBC just released the first official
images of Peter Capaldi's new Doctor
Who outfit
and he's a Magician! No I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding, but I did want to talk
about the top five things that are
really awesome about it as well as you
know the top 5 things that
maybe aren't quite so awesome. Just to make sure you guys get a chance to voice your
reactions
slash lols slash rage I'm going to be doing a
Doctor Who series 8 Q&A later this week
Be sure to subscribe to get it
Feel free to post any series 8 related
question you want anything about the
costume
or the plots or anything else. So let's start
off on a positive note, here are the top
five things that I think are good about
this costume.
number five it pays homage to Jon
Pertwee in the news release the BBC sent
out they didn't address this specifically
they just address the absence of frills
like ruffles and a scarf
I'm not sure why the added no scarf line
but it definitely looks like the third
doctors costume.
number four its age-appropriate Peter
Capaldi is actually one of the
oldest people to play the doctor so
not wearing Sand shoes like tennant it is a
plus
they really played at the old-timeyness of
all Matt Smith's costumes and
yes it worked because
his doctor was a silly. But Capaldi's
Doctor is supposed to be much sterner
much more serious. A la the heat vision
eyes he was giving off during the
50th anniversary.
number three it honors the eleventh
Doctor's outfit.
One of them anyway. Each new doctor gets
to pick his own first outfit
Although Moffat does get a few Vetos. It's
really cool that Capaldi chose to
keep the purple waistcoat aspect of
Smith's Doctor.
As well as the black boots. They're
similar but not the same.
Capaldi's wearing Doc Martens and
Matt Smith wore 18-hole lace-ups.
Number two it's much more practical. the
no frills
and plain-nessof it make it seem like
we're headed for a much more serious
Series 8.
The costume and personality of the Doctor
really do set the tone
and if he dresses an acts in a much more
stern serious way
doesn't that mean that the stories are
going to be that much darker? We can
talk about that more during the Q&A.
And my Number One good thing about the
new costume. There is no neckwear.
With 13 different actors to play the
role, counting John Hurt,
it's almost impossible to wear any
article of clothing without it looking
like an homage too a previous Doctor.
and with exception to maybe the fez and
the Cape, things worn around the neck
have always been the most identifiable
piece of the Doctor's costumes.
So the easiest way to differentiate
yourself is to just not wear anything.
True Jon Pertwee also had a version of his
costume without neckwear,
But he did have ruffles, and thank God
that ruffles are not making a comeback.
So now let's talk about the top five
things that maybe aren't so great about
the costume.
number five it doesn't have the worn-in
look all the other doctors previous
outfits.
Yes Capaldi is a brand new Doctor, but
his clothes are supposed to come from
the TARDIS' wardrobe.
So he typically picks articles of
clothing that he's picked up over the
course of the last 1000 years or so.
Clean clothes are nice, but I feel like
the doctors out that should look like
it's already got a lotta city miles on
it.
Like a really used car. Number four the reveal
only came because they were getting
ready to film outdoors. It would have
been nice to have a big official reveal.
But the only reason they really
showed us his costume was because
images were getting ready to leak. I
don't have a huge problem with this, but
the news was more reaction to that,
rather than a grand unveiling.
Number three, not acknowledging the
similarities to previous Doctor's
costumes.
All the official news release said was
"no frills no scarf". Clearly we can see
aspects of
the third Doctor's costume, why not
officially acknowledge it?
Even if it is just a coincidence. Pertwee
would have been one of Capaldi's
first Doctors to watch. He would have
been about 12 whenever the third
Doctor's run started.
So it's possible that some of that rubbed off
on him when it came time for him to pick
his own Doctor's outfit.
Number two, he's a Magician. The third
Doctor's up it was intentionally silly
because that was something that the
style at the time. Capaldi might not
be wearing a cape,
but the red lining gives him this Magician
look that has kept the people of tumblr
very busy,
as you can see. And my Number one thing
that's not quite so hot about the costume.
There is no neckwear. Yes I realize I said
this earlier,
and yes it's important to be different,
but I can't help but feel that neck
where is such a big part of
Doctor Who that eventually Capaldi will
have to wear some,
even if it's only as a momentary
reference or joke. So now it's your turn
to let me know what is your reaction to
this new costume positive or negative.
Remember in that Q&A I'll be including my
favorite reactions from your'
comments.
Not just the funny ones though, So let me know what you think. Be sure to SUBSCRIBE to
get that video I'll try to post it by
Friday.
Right now click here for my Doctor Who
Series 8 Predictions and click here for
my Sherlock Series 4 Predictions.
THANK YOU so much for watching, I'll see you
guys tonight, high fives!